ok so this
to introduce Imogen heart who teaches in
the history
apartment at the University of
California Berkeley she is the author of
arts and crafts objects with manchester
university press from 2010 and co-editor
with jason edwards of rethinking the
interior 1867 to 1896 aestheticism and
arts and crafts estate she's published
essays on William Morris the Arts and
Crafts movement and Victorian and
Edwardian painting in edited collections
and journals including art history
previously Imogen was a postdoctoral
research associate and an assistant
curator at the Yale Center for British
art she is taught in the history of art
departments at University of York
Bristol Birmingham and here at Yale
imagens current research projects
include sculpture in the age of Darwin
which explores late nineteenth and early
twentieth century sculpture in Britain
and the United States in relation to
evolutionary theory and the unity of the
Arts writing about fine and decorative
arts together on which subjects you will
chair a session at the CAA conference in
2016 so please join me in welcoming
Imogen
let me begin by thanking the organizers
very much for the opportunity to be part
of this wonderful conference an
exhibition of modern British crafts
toured north america between 1942 and
1945 the exhibition opened at the
Metropolitan Museum of Art and traveled
to 14 other destinations across the East
Coast canada and the midwest the display
incorporated furniture ceramics glass
embroidery lace tapestry printed and
woven textiles wallpaper metalwork
calligraphy book binding and toys some
exhibits were displayed in cases while
others were arranged in room
installations for the director of the
toledo museum of art blakemore Godwin
the projects political implications were
clear we want to make it a very
important showing he wrote as I feel
very strongly that England and America
must work together for a long time to
come if the post-war world is to be
anything in which we want to live
another correspondent wrote I am sure it
has served in a most effective way to
create a better understanding of the
english in america after stating the
need for closer sympathies between
nations he added i believe that on your
part the sending of the exhibition of
modern british crafts is one of the most
effective gestures in this direction
that either country has made in this
paper I will argue that the exhibition
reinforced the idea of a cultural
heritage shared by Britain and the
United States by positioning itself as a
legacy of William Morris and the arts
and crafts movement he inspired on both
sides of the Atlantic I will also
consider the show in relation to war
related British visual culture
circulating in the United States and two
other wartime exhibitions in the
Northeast momas Britain at war of 1941
and the Worcester Museum of Art
43 exhibition of New England handicrafts
the introduction to the modern British
crafts catalogue opened with the
deferential reference to William Morris
declaring that the object of this
exhibition is a modest one to show that
the lamp pilot in 1888 is still burning
according to alan eaten an influential
American supporter of craft that purpose
the exhibition accomplished perfectly
and in so doing it stimulates the Arts
and Crafts movement in our country
beyond the power of anyone to comprehend
it welds the spirit of our two countries
together in a stronger bond of freedom
work and beauty more than four decades
had passed since Morris's death yet one
catalog author declared William Morris
is near enough to our own time to be
called contemporary another claimed that
the Arts and Crafts movement has now
been over half a century in progress
even though some critics were already
announcing the end of the Arts and
Crafts movement in the early 20th
century and the interwar crafts revival
was often seen as a separate movement
some practitioners included in the
modern British crafts exhibition such as
ethyl Mary were wary of a
backward-looking arts and crafts
philosophy the exhibition organisers may
have recognized however that Morris and
the Arts and Crafts movement were
associated with an established tradition
of anglo-american exchange eaten
declared I do not believe that any other
type of exhibition could do as much as
this one does to make us conscious of
our superb inheritance from England and
the British Isles the exhibition of
modern British crafts was understood to
continue a tradition of transatlantic
exchange that during the war could stand
for a perm firm political alliance it
was important to claim that the
exhibition represented continuity rather
than change partly because of the strong
desire to dissociate the exhibition from
propaganda the British Council worked
closely with the British Library of
information in New York to organize the
exhibition as both institutions were
aware
pagando propaganda was understood to be
a particularly sensitive issue in the
United States yet the British Council's
Chairman's dated in 1940 it is a
fundamental paradox that the political
effect of cultural propaganda increases
in proportion to its detachment from
political propaganda one museum director
thought the exhibition much more
valuable than any more direct form of
propaganda craft have the advantage of
being both abstract and familiar the
exhibition secretary reported that a
display of domestic objects like this
does not present the barrier of
strangeness many feel in regard to
modern painting adding that in many
cities it attracted sections of the
public who had never visited the museum
before by not depicting the war the
exhibition of modern British crafts
seemed to distance itself from
propaganda and at the same time it's
abstraction was believed to be less
alienating than that of contemporary
fine art the exhibition of modern
British crafts focused on the past and
the future the vast majority of the
exhibits had been produced before the
war this may have been a political
decision as there was fear that
anti-british elements in the USA might
feel that raw materials sent over for
war purposes under the terms of the
lease lend bill were being used for the
production of exhibits the catalogue
explained that craft practitioners and
materials were now reallocated to war
work the show the spoken astatically of
the lost time of peace and handicraft
one case presented ancient and modern
comparisons juxtaposing objects from the
16th to 18th centuries with more recent
ones in a statement that seems designed
to reinforce an anglo-american bond the
catalogue presented the ancient objects
as the common heritage of the
english-speaking peoples the opening
section of the exhibition was devoted to
basic crafts of the soil including a
broom a shepherd's crook horse collar
and a hay rake while the display called
tradition
crafts featured baskets in old type
Shetland straw work and knitted
guernsey's thick oil sweaters made by
fishermen's wives an unidentified source
quoted in a review claimed that there is
little fundamental difference between
rural exhibits in this exhibition and
similar implements in pottery made
hundreds of years ago in England all
those handmade in the agricultural
communities of the United States eaton
wrote how reminiscent these objects are
of pioneer america and of such areas as
the southern highlands parts of New
England of our Southwest where much of a
handicraft kept culture still remains he
drew attention to specific examples
noting both the cartwheel and the
spinning wheel in the British crafts
exhibition struck me as powerful symbols
of European civilization transplanted to
the Western world for eaton the objects
on display represented a long
established tradition of cultural
exchange between Britain and the u.s.
the welding power of the exhibition is
very great he observed because it
includes so many objects that are as
characteristic of America as of Britain
there are strong echoes of the basic
crafts of the soil display in the
nineteen forty three exhibition of
contemporary New England handicrafts at
the Worcester museum of art one of the
venues that had hosted the exhibition of
modern British crafts in an article
announcing the new england handicrafts
exhibition museum director Charles
Sawyer stated plans for the Worcester
exhibition have been inspired by the
British crafts exhibition it included
similar objects such as knitted sweaters
baskets a rake brooms aside a jug and an
ox yoke eaten similarly embraced the
exhibition's reinforcement of a
transatlantic arts and truck arts and
crafts tradition in his exhibition
review he wrote i believe that the
single greatest influence upon american
taste in relation to the things of
everyday use came to us through the arts
and crafts movement initiated in Cariad
carried on in england by william morris
and his associates and successes he
added that the Arts and Crafts movement
affected no country so much as it
affected the United States to which it
came at just the right time to influence
the formation of many arts and crafts
organizations throughout our country one
such organization the society of arts
and crafts Boston founded in 1897 was
represented alongside numerous others in
Worcester New England handicrafts
exhibition the following year in his
foreword to the catalog of the Worcester
exhibition eaten again discussed the
influence of Morris and the arts and
crafts movement on the United States and
on New England in particular the
exhibition of modern British crafts also
looked to the future as one reviewer put
it there is a feeling of hope in the
exhibition of British crafts the message
of hope was consistent with the shows at
a vocation of an arts and crafts past
there was a utopian element to arts and
crafts ideology Morris Feynman famously
expressed antipathy toward his own
present insisting to find anything
beautiful we must look before and after
Morris is well known and often
criticized for looking before to an
idealized medieval world of
collaborative guilds and expressive
craftsmanship but he also looked after
for example in his utopian novel news
from nowhere which imagines the world
after a socialist revolution amid fears
that craft was in serious danger of
dying out due to wartime controls of
materials and labor they were calls to
invest in its future to ensure its
survival in practical terms the
exhibition opened up an international
market British craft as one catalog also
put it the craftsmen in the precious
metals could hardly make a living if he
had not growing support from individual
collectors and patrons of whom there are
more in America than anywhere else in
the world the exhibition had originally
been conceived by potter bernhard leach
and former gallery owner muriel rose as
a way of supporting practitioners during
wartime the little gallery which Rosa
to exhibit modern craft in the interwar
years had been forced to close by the
war Rose accompanied the exhibition of
modern British crafts on it store and
played an important role in installing
the show and interpreting it for
audiences nicholaus pevsner had written
in his foreword to the 1941 exhibition
of the arts and crafts exhibition
Society in London it is not a matter of
materials but of faith one must believe
in the future of crafts to help in and
depreciate such an exhibition the
exhibition of modern British crafts
similarly called for faith the
exhibition focused attention on the work
that had been done before the war and
invited viewers to imagine what craft
workers skills experience and vision
could achieve once it was over although
it diverted attention to the past in the
future the exhibition was of course
framed by the war in the present the
curator of paintings at the mfa boston
declared this exhibition stands for the
kind of life we are fighting to preserve
the successful voyage of the objects
across hostile seas was remarked on
several times there were also a handful
of wartime exhibits among the about
among the objects including the
commemorative silver Dunkirk Cup most
importantly the exhibition was part of
the wartime picture that Britain
presented to the United States and it
needs to be understood in relation to
the broader visual culture that crossed
the Atlantic there is something jarring
about these immaculate ordered
meticulously curated interior spaces
presented against the invisible but
inevitable backdrop of the war the
exhibition displayed in roses words
domestic objects closely related to the
daily life of visitors of every sort
groups and arrangements suggesting rooms
it was an exhibition of the modern
British home back in Europe bombardment
of civilian areas brought the work war
into countless homes artists produced
poignant images that depicted a
threatened ravaged abandoned domesticity
such images would have been extremely
familiar to the American audiences who
attended the exhibition of modern
British crafts it opened at the
Metropolitan Museum of Art on May 22nd
1942 almost exactly a year before on May
twenty-third 1941 the Museum of Modern
Art had launched the exhibition Britain
at war visitors who purchased the
Britain at war catalog would have taken
home examples from Graham Sutherlands
devastation series photographs of bonds
at bomb sites and Edward our design is a
pub in silver town also in New York in
1941 bloody but unbowed pictures of
Britain under fire was published
featuring among others this scene of
relocated de master sir tea and in 1943
an issue of war pictures by British
artists published in London New York and
Toronto focused on the subject of air
raids it produced many paint reproduced
many paintings of destroyed buildings by
Sutherland John Piper and others
including business as usual by Bertram
how it Lodge framed by the debris are
incongruous remnants of middle-class
limit living spaces in business as usual
the furniture seems to have been set up
outside the front of the building
presumably because the interior is
uninhabitable recalling the displacement
captured in the photograph in a pub in
silver town the roof has been blown away
to expose the room part of which remains
in tax the furniture staying in place
despite the steeply sloping floor by
allowing the sofas to defy gravity our
designate conveys an eerie sense of dis
juncture between the irrational and
resilient interior with its immovable
furniture and the destruction around it
similarly the furniture and business as
usual seem stubbornly to resist
submitting to the surrounding chaos a
jagged line on the ground marks the
border of cleanliness and order the dust
having been swept away while at the left
edge a chest of drawers is placed at a
right angle to the wall defiantly
shutting
to the rubble from the domestic scene in
each case of Prim ornament ality clashes
with the grim dirty setting the curves
on the arms of the sofa and the armchair
the pink and white patterned wallpaper
in one and the pink and white ceramics
and the other the gold framed paintings
the only living figure in each is a
passerby a running man in one and a
cautious cat and the other leaving these
spaces uninhabited there is something
haunting about the unsettling ability of
objects and spaces to withstand complete
annihilation so that's popped so that
pockets of order and traces of art
remain meanwhile the incongruity of the
domestic reasserting itself outdoors
amid chaos defies expectations and draws
attention to the permeable borders
between public and private space john
farley president of the arts and crafts
exhibition society and a member of the
committee that organized the exhibition
of modern british crafts wrote of the
degrading exposure he witnessed at bomb
sites two nights after the bombing of
Coventry in 1940 at this moment it's
people are being dug out of the evil
heap of bricks dust and household
remains those bits and pieces that
reveal the pathos of men's lives the
sides of the house are torn away
exposing the dirty linen he describes
with some discuss to the quality of the
objects uncovered noting for example how
the wallpaper hangs down in shreds
revealing the vulgarity of preceding
generations as layer after layer of
hideous patterns come to light a few
months later he continues in a similar
vein surely there is a warning here that
the permanent materials we use should be
made worthy by the form they are given
at least this war has provided the
moment to throw into the melting pot the
vast store of brass litters lizards sham
iron columns and miles of railing that
railings that had no virtue in them
finally attempts to salvage from the
suffering and destruction a call to arms
for craftspeople and designers he
suggests in a later article that the
Englishman's home is
the most significant exhibition of the
culture of this country it is a fact
that might well give us pause to think
it is certain that we are judged as a
nation more by the home of the
individual than is generally realized
the destruction of homes caused caused
by bombardment provides an important
context for understanding the exhibition
of modern British crafts the show
presented a vision of the modern British
home for inspection it's installations
both denied and echoed the widely
circulating images of destruction
zooming out from the immersive views of
the room displays we see how abruptly
they are separated off from the gallery
space the neatly laid out clean
harmonious interior is just like a real
room except that the fourth wall has
been removed and we are able to look in
there is a striking visual analogy with
the representations of partially intact
private interiors exposed to public view
by the action of bombs the installations
call to mind the violence done to
similar rooms and objects and of course
to their inhabitants it has been
observed that in many images of the
aftermath of bombing buildings appear
distinctly anthropomorphic as Brian
Foster puts it these brooding paintings
shift death onto semi-human
architectural shells similarly Farley
saw the experience of bombardment
reflected back to him by his furniture
on being awoken by a bomb that shook the
house he recalled I looked for
reassurance in the familiar objects
around but the furniture stared back at
me hard clear and antipathetic either
the inanimate objects had become
sentient like myself or I had become
inanimate with them for there were a few
terrifying moments of identification
myself with them or they with me I could
not tell which in these circumstances
objects cease to be still unstable and
become uncanny correspondingly the
objects and rooms in the exhibition of
modern British crafts are both empty and
full of human presence
like the abandoned structures endlessly
documented by war artists these spaces
are melancholy they are echoes of the
defunct workshops where the objects were
produced one of the poignant messages of
the catalogue was the craft production
have been halted by the war silence
studios and absent makers were called to
mind by the photographs of British
craftsmen at work affixed to the outside
of the room installations some of which
were reproduced in the catalog these
images of healthy productive peaceful
labour acquire an elegiac quality in
this context for example the centerpiece
of the town dining room was a dining
table and chair set designed by eric
ravilious whose plane was lost in action
in 1942 during the exhibition's tall one
entry in the catalogue for a book
binding called the Battle of Britain
states that the inside front cover is
inlaid with a piece of plush given by
their Majesties the king and queen from
the bombed chapel at Buckingham Palace
many objects were lent by the
Goldsmith's company whose building had
been damaged by a bomb in 1941 the
aftermath was recorded in a painting by
Phyllis ginger that was reproduced and
circulated in war pictures by British
artists in 1943 the exhibits included a
cigarette box commemorating outstanding
work in the preservation of Goldsmith's
Hall during the night bombing raids on
London this and other objects lent by
Goldsmith's company attempted to replace
destruction with production much like
the exhibition as a whole as Christopher
reads important scholarship has shown
the domestic has been denigrated and
feminized in histories of modernism read
observes that as its military derived
name suggests the avant-garde imagined
itself away from home marching toward
glory on the battlefields of culture
thanks to Clement Greenberg the
avant-garde is also opposed to catch in
the discourses of modernism
alissa author argues that for greenberg
the decorative is catch quoting the
latter's comment in 1941 when the
abstract artist grows tired he becomes
an interior decorator during the war
reads point about the military
associations of the avant-garde is
particularly opposite water countless
recruits including artists and
craftspeople away from home in light of
the feminization and repression of the
domestic in histories of modernism it is
significant that the exhibition of
modern British crafts drew attention
both to the work of women and to art in
a domestic context fewer than ten
percent of the named artists in the
catalogue of the Britain at war
exhibition were women by contrast nearly
forty percent of the exhibitors named in
the catalogue of modern British crafts
show were women and the proportion of
women represented was probably much
higher than that since many exhibitors
were simply listed as companies or
groups a similar proportion of the
contributors to the New England
handicrafts exhibition were women the
exhibition of modern British crafts may
have contributed both negatively and
positively to the mid-century discourse
around decoration femininity and
modernism on the one hand the fact that
this was a craft exhibition and featured
many women artists may have reinforced
the association of women with the
decorative a complicated but often
devalued category in the United States
at this moment on the other hand the
exhibition foregrounded the domestic
revealed that women had been extremely
active in the interwar British crafts
revival and found them customers in
North America it also blurred boundaries
by including objects designed by male
artists whose paintings had been
displayed in Britain at war such as
Sutherland ravilious and Edward Borden
finally the exhibition may have played a
small part in nurturing the post war
craft revival that developed in the
United States local craftspeople were
encouraged to handle the objects in the
exhibition and many reported the
exhibition was that the experience was
instructive and inspiring in reinforcing
what has been called the myth of the
p artisan the exhibition not only
aligned itself with the idealism and
romanticism of the Arts and Crafts
movement but also invited interpretation
in the context of rehabilitation and
occupational therapy for wounded and off
duty servicemen a roll crafts performed
in both countries the catalogue declared
the artists and craftsmen of the United
States are now in the unenviable
position as those are great britain eat
and wrote to the british council nothing
could have been so helpful to what we
are calling the american handicraft
movement as this british exhibition it
answers with an overwhelming affirmative
the question which many of us have been
asking should we keep on in our vital
work for handicrafts countless Americans
will long be grateful to you for this
fine encouragement of a common cause to
conclude the exhibition was an assertion
of transatlantic solidarity and at the
same time it was a manifesto for the
importance of craft in the modern world
the conservatism nationalism and
nostalgia of the exhibition should not
obscure its defiant utopianism and it's
potentially radical purpose in bringing
handicraft women domesticity and the
legacy of a socialist leaning Arts and
Crafts movement to center stage in a
time of war thank
you